I'm Samantha Ashe de velde it on Madison
beating thank you for watching
we're taking over real rejects today
because Ryan is very lame and did a
little watch every day this video he did
not want to watch Backstreet Boys show
em what you're made of official trailer
he's very lame I mean who wouldn't want
to watch this we get to watch it I mean
I'm a nineties child it's classic
Backstreet Boys way so I haven't heard a
lot about this other than there's a big
hype around it it's a documentary
so I heard nothing about it but you
gotta love the Backstreet Boys so let's
bring it back let's watch this document
what do you do when you're a full grown
man and a boy band I had this idea to go
to London just the five of us and the
record album no families no girlfriends
just us
was one of the wealthiest men in Orlando
at the time who had seen the success of
boys to men new kids on the block that
he was like well I can do this
I can put together this group at that
time radio is playing the vana and Snoop
Dogg there was no room for boys like
guys I think you guys should go to
Europe it just became this world we had
sold 14 million albums of our first
indeed
this is not just a regular door this is
a big deal happens 300 million dollars
he stole or was missing we've seen the
best and the worst of each other anymore
years a long time for anybody no five
bunch of dorks jumping around on stage
saying WOW interesting I've never been
like a die-hard I could sing like two of
their songs but I never listening to it
as I grew old but old what old lady try
and not give away my age job I was in
impressed with this seems to be like the
it thing is you know we did it with Katy
Perry and burn everybody's doing what I
read shame and so when I heard it was
kind of like okay
but anything was kind of cool about this
is that there's a lot of us that you
know have grown up with them at this
point it's not you know it Katy Perry
she did a very quick like she hit the
scene and there's documentary and that's
fantastic so I don't know this might be
cool cuz this brings it back
backstreet's back alright isn't making
it seem like we're asleep and just ruin
our you know video he's also the
one-on-one time we get right now and
maybe a little afraid of what could
happen when we take over I mean he
doesn't know what just happened yeah I
don't know I probably won't watch this
but I maybe would eventually I don't
know if I'd go to the theater yeah I
wouldn't go to the theater to watch it
but it is intriguing I think
you sit together it looks like you know
it was pieced together pretty well it
might be kind of nice to hear their side
of the story with their whole journey
though what was interesting what they
said about how they were big in Europe
first before America that's that was
that's crazy and nobody over here you
even heard that first album yeah and I
think it's always good to see a peak in
well here's the thing how about this we
don't want to watch them feeders how
about you and I watch it we'll just
chill and watch it we're in a house
there is more to it like no we're not
gonna watch it Sears where'd you learn
it was a watch it no what did you think
Beverly did you think it was good I like
the fact that they're doing this
documentary now because they get to go
back and reflect what they were saying
in it you know from the past 20 years
they've been a group together for a long
time and yes they broke up and took some
time but that's a lot of time like they
they have some monumental
accomplishments together so I think it's
pretty well I can respect them of the
fact that they can still all perform
together well I mean you get on this set
with people for a month and you know
most of the time you get lucky and you
come out as a family but sometimes it's
like a huge struggle and then think
about how much time they spent together
there's such a bond there but the fact
that after 20 years all five of you can
still come together and make music and
the music they were making wasn't bad
yeah that they're modern day that
they're doing I'm actually interested to
hear their new album look like they're
making possibly Anna well and that's
great because my brother had no idea the
Backstreet Boys is but I'll be like
Backstreet Boys alright okay okay it'll
be interesting to see what happens I
feel like this is supposed to launch
them into something else again
like trying to get them back on the map
all right thank you go please subscribe
to the real rejects check out if you
like what we're doing here
there's plenty more and Ryan as normally
in the videos that again he was too lame
to be in this one so you got us in which
by the way check out
Madison's channel thank you it's Madison
official Sen and you've got to check out
Sam's channel if you check out mine I
mean I mean we're kind of a package deal
you have to at UVU one you're not
getting a choice
please who should be shout out wishes
shout out Ryan may left us yes Ryan
right right you gonna shout having us on
your show your [ __ ] awesome
absolutely ridiculous and offensive and
I say offensive and likes to talk about
[ __ ] lots of [ __ ] for the record I don't
think it's okay to [ __ ] on girl's chest
pimp
pimps getting started in the babes game
sorry Cathy fired up he keeps trying to
put out there but he's doing something
right if you're fired up we're talking
the fact that you're different you like
to have you
we don't I was really just enjoying
listening to your wonderful voice
I suggest you mean I don't laud please